ich meine wer wahrscheinlich mitbekommen
hatte
ich bin gerade in new york zusammen mit
und wir haben schon beim irischen
anderen youtube angesehen dass die in
verschiedenen rohstoffen so videos macht
anbieter strangers und irgendwann spielt
also ist man einfach mit unbekannten
leuten irgendwie zusammen ein foto macht
oder so da wir dann auf die schnelle
komplett zu machen und zu weiteren
sportler mit gedacht dass wir heute
einfach mit unbekannten ort machen und
das jetzt immer abwechselnd in die erde
vielleicht gefällt euch
helden
b
reagiert
hey
hallo freunde ich mich gerade so schnell
ich habe das ende bearbeitet und hat mir
aufgefallen dass videos zwei minuten
landes werden das ganze aufgenommen
jeder hat acht oder neun teams mit
anderer leute gemacht und wir dachten
das ist viel zu viel hoffentlich können
wir das alles in ein video reihe
allerdings denkst du das video ist
irgendwie zwei minuten lang
das setzt allerdings ein video ist wo
ich einfach noch etwas dran hängen kann
sondern wir die selbst wirklich in new
york gemacht haben und jetzt nicht
überzeugt mit new york fliegen kann habe
ich mir gedacht mach' ich heute einfach
gleich noch ein zweites video das heißt
ich werde gleich am abend noch ein
zweites video hochladen reinig technisch
noch eins allerdings hat das video ist
es mir wirklich viel zu kurz und ich hab
eigentlich online machen möchte kommt
heute am 9 2
deswegen hoffe ich euch ja das ganze
gefallen wer das getan hat würde ich
mich über einen daumen hoch freuen und
dann sehen wir uns im video heute ab